3 de febrero de 1802 los barcos del
general víctor manuel el clan
desembarcan en santo domingo su cuñado
napoleón bonaparte primer cónsul le ha
dado órdenes muy claras retomar la
colonia francesa dirigida por tussam
lübeck yo porque napoleón ha tomado una
decisión que pretende hacer cumplir
restablecer la esclavitud de las
colonias francesas era casi seguro que
tan pronto como llegara al poder había
un plan para restablecer el antiguo
sistema colonial es decir la esclavitud
de estados la esclavitud fue abolida por
la convención de la revolución francesa
en 1794 pero cuando napoleón bonaparte
llegó al poder tenía un objetivo
restaurar el imperio colonial francesa
en américa y explotar al máximo sus
recursos ya no lo vi hay un lobby y los
colonos los armadores sus comerciantes o
fabricantes que piensan que la vuelta a
la esclavitud significaría el regreso de
la riqueza y la prosperidad en santo
domingo los combates continúan
jean-jacques dessalines sucesor de
tussam lo vio derrota a las tropas de
buena parte
haití
[Música]
es este recuerdo grabado en el corazón
la cabeza y el alma de todos los
haitianos eso es lo que recuerdan de
napoleón el que quería restablecer la
esclavitud y contra el que las tropas de
los que van descalzos de santo domingo
como se llamaban a sí mismos tomaron las
armas y derrotaron a las tropas de la iv
perderían wikileaks visión en 1802 otra
colonia se rebeló guadalupe pero aquí la
revuelta fracasó y la esclavitud se
restableció en la isla que sigue siendo
un departamento francés las
conmemoraciones del bicentenario de la
muerte de napoleón despiertan un
recuerdo muy doloroso
hoy todos tenemos el deber de exigir la
rehabilitación de nuestros antepasados y
que se respeten nuestra historia que no
se reescriba la historia simplemente por
la gloria de un hombre y por sus leyes y
decretos de 1802 napoleón convirtió
francia en el único país del mundo en
haber restablecido la esclavitud después
de haberla abolido